in this video we'll be ranking the
original british children's harry potter
book covers as part of our series to
create the
ultimate harry potter jacket art tier
list people love the internet
retro recontour here if we're meeting
for the first time i'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell we
post videos every week here including
old school harry potter let's plays
hogwarts legacy news and plenty more
if you're interested in that then make
sure you subscribe so you won't miss any
of our new videos
if you didn't know the harry potter
books have been translated into more
than 80 different languages and i
thought it would be a fun idea to look
at the art from around the world to see
which covers are the best
we'll be using a scale inspired by owls
from the harry potter series which means
top marks will deem outstanding followed
by exceeds expectations
acceptable poor and then troll at the
bottom
we'll be basing this tier list solely on
the front covers and not the full jacket
arc as always remember this is all in
good fun and no offense is meant to any
of the original illustrators of these
covers
remember the great thing about art is
that it's open to your interpretation so
i
invite your feedback after you've
watched let me know if you agree with
any of these and of course if you think
i'm wrong on any of these let me know
about that as well
okay moving on to the british editions
here now these are the british
children's editions when these came out
in the uk as my uk
friends know they also released adult
editions as well those were just
i don't know kind of boring to be honest
with you in my opinion so i went with
the kids edition here for our tier list
also i know you can't see the american
rating right now but don't worry at the
end i'm going to put all of them back up
there so you can see how all of them
stack up together
okay starting off with the british
editions we have harry potter and
the philosopher's stone and we've got
harry depicted here with the scar
and standing in front of the hogwarts
express you can see platform nine and
three quarters in the background
now this one was also quite iconic for
me because i remember
looking online and being like whoa
that's the original you know this is the
first
one that came out harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
but sorry to my uk friends to me this
one just does not capture that same
level of magic that i got from
mary grand praise sorcerer stone so for
me
this one's okay there's nothing that i
really dislike strongly about it but
it's just not all that great to me
there's nothing that really jumps out
and says oh my goodness
this is a book about magic in this crazy
world
that this young man is going to find so
for me i'm going to put this one in the
acceptable category
don't hate me guys i'm sorry harry
potter and the chamber of secrets
honestly i don't love the way that harry
and ron
look in this one to be to be totally
honest i do like how you kind of have
the clouds going along with the ford
anglia
almost looks like it's kind of a part of
the clouds
you got headwig in the back there but to
be honest
yet again this one is just acceptable
for me i mean there's nothing that
screams
magic here okay fine you do have a
flying car
i admit but again there's just to me
there's nothing
super magical about this one just kind
of okay for me
okay harry potter and the prisoner of
azkaban the bloomsbury edition here
again we see the same scene harry and
hermione writing buckbeak here
in front of the moon there in the
background now what i really do love
about this one is how the moon serves
that
extra purpose at first glance or before
you read the book you wouldn't even
think about the fact that oh there might
be a werewolf involved
and one thing that i'm not sure if was
intentional or not
i'm pretty sure this part up here is
meant to be hermione's cloak but doesn't
that kind of look like a dementor a
little bit to you as well
i don't know if that's intentional like
if it's hinting that maybe that's a
dementor
all in all though again another
acceptable cover here
now we're talking this one an awesome
action scene
of course this is showing the task where
harry has to take on
the hungarian horntail and he's going
for the egg there
on his broom i love the way the dragon
looks here i love the way we get this
action shot of harry racing over to get
the egg
this one definitely exceeds expectations
for me
harry potter and the order of the
phoenix this one right here is probably
my favorite cover of the british
editions
fox is obviously one of the most
incredible magical creatures in the
entire
series and this fact that this one is
named order of the phoenix it only makes
sense this is a great time
to be able to use fox on the cover of
course fox also plays a prominent role
near the
end of the book when he takes on a
killing curse
from voldemort it's aimed at dumbledore
of course
box gets kind of exploded there for the
moment but we know
he's eventually reborn this one another
exceeds
expectations okay harry potter and the
half blood prince
first of all i love this scene choice
much better than
the american the married grand prairie
edition i think this was the right
choice for
the scene this is such an incredible
moment of course we know dumbledore is
in a very weakened state here we'll
we're building toward that climax that's
going to happen at the top of the
astronomy tower just
a few pages after this scene takes place
i don't
love the way that dumbledore and harry
look here i get that they're meant to be
under incredible distress
i'm not a huge fan of the way they're
portrayed but because of the fact that i
think
what the illustrator is going for here
is that this is in a very intense moment
obviously for them dumbledore
fearing for his life knows what's about
to come he's just drank this horrible
potion and harry is kind of freaking out
like dude i don't even know what i'm
doing here
so i think i will put that one in
exceeds expectations
as well and finally harry potter and the
deathly hallows the british
children's edition guys i gotta be
honest i'm torn on this one i'm torn on
this one
i want to love this cover i i really do
because it is so unique i love the look
on
ron and hermione's faces just like the
sheer terror that ron has at what's
going on
it's almost more humorous for me though
than grand
epic conclusion to this incredible
series to me
it's not powerful enough to show just
how incredible that book is and i
realize that's a tall task to make a
piece of artwork that
captures the spirit of the book that
gets people interested
this would get me interested in the book
i would be intrigued
to read this even if i didn't know what
was going on here but ultimately i just
have to go with another acceptable here
so let's pull in our rating for the
american editions now so we can compare
these all together
by the way not really sure what i'm
going to do here as we add more covers
but hey we'll figure that out when the
time comes i suppose
anyway you can see that so far most of
the covers are falling into the x seeds
expectations
and acceptable categories so far we only
have two earning top marks without
standing and we haven't had any so far
fall into poor or troll
let me know which harry potter book
covers you'd like to see me rank next
and as always thank you so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon